je partirai quand même sur l'article du
bruit
à la limite je suis même pas obligé de
le lire je peux vous le faire comme ça
vous mettre le lien dans le chat et si
ça vous intéresse
de toute façon le lien vous le retrouver
facilement
et si ça vous intéresse vous le prenez
une fois que vous êtes à l'aise mais
franchement si vous faites des séances
sociales allez-y donc l'illusion
biographique alors Bourdieu quand j'ai
lu l'article il met un peu retourné deux
fois bon qu'est-ce qui nous raconte
Pierre Bourdieu il nous dit qu'en fait
quand tu demandes à quelqu'un de
raconter sa vie
bah c'est pas très juste c'est pas très
juste parce que il va te raconter sa vie
comme si il y avait un sens comme s'il y
avait un sens de l'histoire comme s'il y
avait un début et un mouvement et que
toutes les expériences venaient au bon
moment c'est un briquet parce que la
personne elle a reconstruit sa vie
évidemment alors il fait la référence à
Maupassant j'aime beaucoup Maupassant
aussi et au livre une vie qui est le mot
passant que je préfère aussi ou en fait
c'est le roman qui traite de la vie
d'une bourgeoise
de Normandie je pense c'est la Normandie
à Maupassant
et donc on te raconte toute sa vie de A
à Z tu sais avec un côté un peu
totalisant comme ça avec un narrateur
qui sait tout et ça c'est la première
illusion biographique
avec des déjà depuis tout petit tu vois
tu vas tu vas romancer ta vie c'est un
peu ça l'idiomographie tu te dis
l'article il va nous parler de ça mais
en fait Bourdieu il te va plus loin
encore parce qu'il te dit en fait
je vais pas dire ton identité parce
qu'il utilise pas le terme
identité dans ce sens-là
ton nom et tout et toute cette toute ton
toit public finalement c'est une
construction sociale alors ça on le
savait mais en fait ton nom n'a pas de
sens et ton nom c'est un coup de force
symbolique alors ça c'est moi qui le dis
il dit pas il dit pas comme ça c'est un
coup de force symbolique qui arrive à
faire la société bon désolé d'utiliser
la société on sait que c'est un beau
four tout qu'il faut pas trop utiliser
pour te donner l'illusion que tu es le
même tout le temps donner une uniformité
dans ta vie alors je vais expliquer un
petit peu ce que ça recouvre tu vois
comme tu vois là tu t'appelles je sais
pas
Sylvain dramey
quel que soit le contexte social dans
lequel tu es quel que soit ton propre
évolution c'est ce Sylvain dramet ce nom
qu'on te colle et cette identité
publique cette identité civile mais
n'utilise pas le terme identité c'est ça
qui est compliqué quand tu expliques un
article c'est que parfois tu te déforme
les mots tu utilises des mots mais qui
sont pas les bons et donc mais bon comme
si tu te dis ça en fait il faut lire
alors à ce moment là et il faut plus
faire de la vulgarisation parce que tu
défends toujours c'est que pour Bourdieu
je vais répondre directement à ta
question de manière très claire pour
Bourdieu en fait ta vie allait exploser
quoi il y a différents moments que tu
vis de manière tout à fait accidentelle
qui vont être fondateurs de ta vie
future quelque part même si c'est pas
très juste de dire ça mais voilà la vie
c'est tout du chaos c'est c'est des
moments où tu es avec des amis et puis
tu es plus du tout le même quand avec ta
famille et puis tu changes et puis tu tu
Renis des choses auxquelles tu avais cru
et ça c'est ta vie c'est un immense
chaos c'est un immense désordre et
Bourdieu le dit très bien voilà pour
Bourdieu c'est le théoricien des champs
donc en fait oui dans le quand élève à
l'école ou étudiant mais et que tu es
face à tes professeurs tu es pas le même
que quand tu es avec tes potes en soirée
ou quand avec ta famille tes enfants
machin tu vois mais ton nom ton
identité civile je vais le dire comme ça
vient mettre un trait uniforme et vient
en fait uniformiser ta vie et c'est ça
l'illusion biographique je vais vous
dire quelques passages et j'espère que
ça illustrera bien le propos c'est
inclination à se faire l'idéologue de sa
propre vie en sélectionnant parce qu'en
plus tu vas sélectionner dans ta vie
quand on te demande de raconter ton
histoire
on sélectionnant en fonction d'une
intention globale comme si ta vie avait
un but mais personne n'a un but dans sa
vie alors il y a un but qu'on se fixe
mais en fait c'est c'est une sorte
d'illusion parce qu'après ce but là va
changer enfin voilà quoi c'est pour
donner du sens à notre vie parce que
sinon ça serait invivable mais il y a
pas de véritable sens on est face à
l'absurde
je suis un grand lecteur de Camus donc
l'absurde ça me parle énormément
donc en fonction d'une intention globale
certains événements significatifs que tu
vas retirer et en établissant entre eux
des connexions propres à leur donner
cohérence comme celle qui implique le
institution en tant que cause ou plus
souvent en tant que fin trouve la
complicité naturelle du biogramme que
tout a commencé par ces dispositions de
professionnels de l'interprétation porte
à accepter cette création artificielle
de sens et donc la littérature elle est
biographe parce que la littérature aussi
l'exemple de d'une vie de Maupassant
nous nous fait croire comme ça que la
vie a une sorte de courant une sorte de
rivière qui coule avec tous des
événements qui ont du sens qui viennent
bien s'imbriquer tout ça et en sciences
sociales c'est ça devient
dangereux parce que tu peux tomber dans
cette illusion là quand tu vas faire des
entretiens qui vont durer longtemps ou
en gros tu vas demander un peu aux gens
de manière très libre de raconter leur
vie
et donc tu peux prendre des vessies pour
des lanternes parce que les individus
vont narrer les choses pour que ça aille
du sens pour que ça soit cohérent mais
peut-être que les choses se sont pas
passées comme ça dans le sens où eux ils
ont oublié des éléments qui étaient
discordants par rapport à cette
continuité à ce fil
voilà Bourdieu nous dit comme si notre
existence était doté de sens de
signification de direction
et toute la tradition littéraire n'a
cessé et ne cesse de renforcer cette
illusion et cette impression alors il
utilise aussi des citations littéraires
un Bourdieu finalement
est un grand amateur de littérature et
nous dit comme l'indique Alain grillé
l'avènement du roman moderne et
précisément lié à cette découverte le
fait que notre vie est complètement
chaotique et elle a un gros briller nous
dit le réel est discontinu former
d'éléments juxtaposés sans raison de
chacun est unique d'autant plus
difficile à saisir qu'il surgisse de
façon sans cesse imprévue hors de propos
et aléatoires et donc c'est ce que dit
Bourdieu notre vie est comme ça et donc
il utilise l'intuition du romancier pour
étayer son propos c'est pas une preuve
c'est plutôt une illustration
parce que pour lui pour Bourdieu voilà
notre vie sociale et fragmentée entre
nos différents nos différents champs de
socialisation nos différents champs
d'activité notre vie professionnelle
notre vie privée notre familiale notre
vie sentimentale et ainsi de suite
la plus évidente et évidemment le nom
propre
qui en tant que désignateur rigide entre
guillemets selon l'expression de
crypties désigne le même objet en
n'importe quel univers possible et donc
il dit cette illusion
est renforcée par des institutions comme
notre nom propre qui vient uniformiser
notre vie entre le
Alain robe grillé à 10 ans et le halalin
65 ans il y a sans doute plus beaucoup
de points communs parce que l'individu a
évolué a changé à subir les chaos de la
vie mais son nom vient uniformiser tout
ça
un peu comme si derrière ce hasard
l'homme cherche du sens exactement c'est
exactement ça et ça c'est l'illusion
biographique le sens qu'on cherche dans
notre existence tu vois entre tous les
événements qu'on a plus vivre et des
choses comme ça et c'est renforcé par le
fait qu'on nous dit ah mais tu es un
seul et unique individu alors évidemment
on est un seul unique individu mais je
me dis après je réfléchissais à ça bon
c'est pour ça que je suis un lecteur
très très long je n'avance pas dans ma
lecture parce que je m'arrête toutes les
5 minutes pour pour rêvasser à ce que
j'ai lu je me dis par exemple voilà ce
qu'on vit ici sur twitch c'est beau
parce que Bourdieu aurait sans doute
trouvé ça intéressant puisqu'on n'est
pas dans une illusion biographique
puisqu'on peut prendre des pseudos
différents et maintenant avec la vie
numérique qu'on peut avoir chacun prend
des identités différentes sur sur le net
et en fait c'est ça c'est ça ça c'est ça
en fait
le nom formeait-il vraiment une identité
alors c'est il n'utilise pas le terme
identité
puisque une personne derrière un nom
change constamment mais exactement c'est
ce qu'il dit et le nom vient
[Musique]
uniformiser donc je reprends le mode
Bourdieu ici viens comme un désignateur
rigide et donc je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi et que zodiaque
la personne change derrière mais le nom
reste
alors il faut pas oublier que cet
article date de 86 donc ça commence à
faire un bail
ça évolue évidemment avec les identités
qui maintenant sont beaucoup plus
fluides avec aussi donc même le nom qui
peut changer ou on peut changer plus
facilement de nom aussi
[Musique]
comment dire le fait que nos données
maintenant on peut essayer de les
protéger plus qu'avant
ou avant voilà on prenait une photo de
toi à l'école primaire on pouvait
maintenant que on peut publier cette
photo là sur facebook tu vois
aujourd'hui ça devient peut-être chi
dans les écoles normalement on doit
demander si les gens sont d'accord qu'on
publie les photos alors on peut être
pour ou contre ça mais voilà je trouve
que on a évolué par rapport à 1986 c'est
ce que nous dit Bourdieu mais n'empêche
que l'illusion biographique reste on
considère tout ce qu'on est des êtres
voilà en continuité alors qu'on est des
êtres fragmentés dans nos vies la
société entre guillemets tout à fait
essayer de donner du sens à la vie des
hommes donc la création de ces
institutions techniquement le fruit des
besoins de l'homme oui ça se tient oui
je suis d'accord avec toi
oui parce que les institutions n'ont pas
de volonté propre on est bien d'accord
et donc en fait je suis assez durcumien
par rapport à ça Durkheim c'est le
fonctionnalisme donc si les choses
existent c'est parce qu'elle remplissent
un rôle et donc voilà ça rejoint ce que
tu dis on en a besoin donc les
institutions vont combler le vide mais
c'est le travail du sociologue à
décrypter ce que ce que font les
institutions et le premier rôle des
sciences sociales selon moi et de
déconstruire comme disait arkan tout à
l'heure de déconstruire ce qui nous
apparaît comme naturel
alors je continue à lire les petits
passages que j'ai flueté hésif qui
décrit le nom propre comme un point fixe
dans un monde mouvant voilà donc un
point fixe notre nom serait un point
fixe dans un monde mouvant
et donc sans ce nom on aurait peut-être
moins cette illusion biographique à
raison de voir dans les rites baptismo
le fait du baptême bon même si le
baptême est en perte de vitesse comme
institution la manière nécessaire
d'assigner une identité par cette forme
tout à fait singulière de nomination de
donner un nom propre à quelqu'un
constitue le nom propre se trouve ainsi
tué une identité sociale à utiliser
constante
et durable qui garantit l'identité de
l'individu biologique dans tous les
champs possibles où il intervient en
tant qu'agent et ça c'est très
intéressant quel que soit ton
intervention tu vas garder toujours le
même nom tu vois il y a cette uniformité
même si tu fais des choses totalement
différentes et si tu comportes de
manière totalement différente bon ça
aussi intéressant toute cette question
des rites moi je dis souvent les rites
ça sert à créer des choses qui
n'existent pas c'est pour donner corps à
des choses qui n'existent pas et donc
quand on dit voilà vous êtes marié et
femme cette union mais en fait cette
union elle est très fragile d'ailleurs
le nombre de mariages qui casse
aujourd'hui montre bien que le mariage
n'est pas une union durable enfin voilà
et donc en fait à quoi sert le mariage à
affirmer tant comme tangible quelque
chose qui est éphémère et fragile et
donc ici pareil et c'est vrai que le
fait au bien de déclarer quelqu'un son
enfant à la commune ou à la municipalité
lui donner un nom voilà c'est tout des
démarches administratives qui vont
donner corps à cette identité sociale
qui n'existe pas réellement quoi qui est
une construction sociale
par cette forme tout à fait singulière
de nomination que constitue le nom
propre se trouve ainsi tué une en
identité sociale constante et durable
qui garantit-il l'identité biologique
dans tous les champs possibles donc moi
je ne lis pas comme comme toi
la forme socialement instituée ce qui
assure la constance à travers le temps
et l'unité à travers les espaces sociaux
donc encore une fois tu vas traverser
tous les espaces sociaux mais tu vas
garder le même nom
sauf sur les espaces numériques donc ça
c'est intéressant il faudrait voir c'est
un objet d'étude de prendre les outils
de bordure et c'est une problématique
intéressante de prendre les outils
conceptuels de Bourdieu et les
transposer sur des objets qui sont
nouveaux comme les espaces sociaux les
espaces de socialisation comme celui
dans lequel nous sommes actuellement
par là il assure aux individus désignés
par de là tous les changements et toutes
les fluctuations biologiques tu vois
Leviathans et social la constante
nominale l'identité au sens de
l'identité à soi-même de Constantia cibi
que demande l'ordre social l'ordre
social a besoin d'une constance si on
change tout le temps d'identité sociale
ce n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
organisable en quelque sorte le prénom
le nom pardon permet de totaliser ces
manifestations dans des enregistrements
officiels non pardon les institutions
donc le curriculum vitae vous allez
mettre votre nom en premier vous voyez
c'est toutes des occasions dans
lesquelles vous avez renforcé cette
identité sociale le casier judiciaire
c'est par rapport à votre nom la
nécrologie c'est par rapport à votre nom
la biographie c'est par rapport à votre
nom c'est un désignateur rigide nous dit
Bourdieu le nom propre et la forme par
excellence de l'imposition arbitraire
coopèrent les rides d'institutions donc
là il y a une sorte de violence
évidemment qui est faite à l'individu et
voilà dans des sociétés libertaires on
refuserait tout non d'ailleurs je pense
que dans certains groupes libertaires
voilà on va se se donner un nouveau nom
ou un pseudo ou un surnom des choses
comme ça quoi
ce qui est logique
bon c'est aussi assez foucalien comme
terme donc ça fait référence aussi à
Foucault le nom permet de contrôler
aussi
s'il y a pas d'identité le contrôle
social est plus difficile
ainsi le nom propre et le support de ce
que l'on appelle l'état civil
c'est-à-dire de cet ensemble de
propriété la nationalité le sexe l'âge
attaché à des personnes auxquelles la
loi civile associe des effets juridiques
et qu'instituts sous apparence de le
constater les actes d'état civil quoi
donc voilà c'est ce qui permet à la
société
de fonctionner mais un certain type de
société on est bien d'accord
elle conduit à construire la notion de
trajectoire comme série de positions
successivement occupés par un même agent
dans un espace lui-même en devenir est
soumis à d'incer sans transformation
donc lui il oppose toujours cet espace
qui est mobile qui est fluctuant et
cette identité qui reste les événements
biographiques se définissent comme
autant de placement de déplacement dans
l'espace social
voilà alors il y a un terme qu'il a
utilisé j'aime beaucoup parce que je
trouve que c'est très juste et c'est un
peu quand on a des des vidéos des
articles de vulgarisation du travail de
Bourdieu et notamment la distinction on
va souvent dire même Bourdieu voilà les
gens ils ont tel goût et tout ça mais
c'est plus compliqué que ça parce que
Bourdieu parle beaucoup de la
trajectoire sociale des individus quand
tu es jeune tu as des goûts qui sont
différents de quand tu seras vieux et ça
dépendra
de ta trajectoire sociale aussi de par
où tu vas passer quoi quelque part tu
vois et donc cette notion de dynamique
est très présente chez Bourdieu et ça on
l'oublie souvent c'est ce qui explique
que voilà tu peux être issu du même
milieu social mais entre des jeunes de
20 ans ou de 15 ans de ce milieu social
là et ce 60 ans il y aura des
différences de comportements de style de
vie alors les gens qui ont pas lu
Bourdieu et qui pensent savoir vont me
dire ah ouais mais pour Dieu voilà ils
au-dessus du même milieu ils font des
choses différentes mais ouais mais
regarde un petit peu leur trajectoire
aussi quoi et donc ici Bourdieu utiliser
un terme que j'avais pas encore vu chez
lui où je m'en souviens pas en tout cas
qui est vieillissement social donc ici
c'est de dire qu'on ne peut comprendre
une 3jectoires c'est-à-dire le
vieillissement social qui bien qui
l'accompagnement est indépendant du
vieillissement biologique qu'à condition
d'avoir préalablement construit les
États susceptifs du champ dans lequel
elle s'est déroulée donc en fait pour
Bourdieu tu ne peux pas comprendre
quelqu'un si tu comprends pas le chant
le contexte social dans lequel il est il
est quoi où il a vécu
[Musique]